ya platicamos acerca de puntos y ya
platicamos acerca de rectas lo que ahora
vamos a hacer es pensar en planos le voy
a poner por aquí planos planos
bueno un plano es simplemente una
superficie delgada en tres dimensiones
que se extiende en todas las direcciones
se extiende para allá para acá para acá
para acá y vaya pues es plano o sea no
es curvo ni nada es una superficie así
totalmente delgada vale bueno lo que nos
interesa ahorita es pensar en cómo
podemos determinar un plano por ejemplo
bastará un punto para determinar un
plano si aquí pongo un punto a habrá un
único plano que pasa por allí en el
espacio pues yo digo que no
por ejemplo pudiéramos tener este plano
de acá este plano y este plano pasa por
el punto a más o menos algo de este
estilo pero hay muchos otros planos que
también pasan por ahí por ejemplo puedo
trazar un plano pues más o menos así así
así y así y este plano también pasa por
a sí básicamente lo que estoy haciendo
es tomar el primer plano y rotarlo
alrededor de a y bueno eso lo puedo
hacer muchísimas veces entonces hay una
infinidad de planos que pasan por el
punto a así que no un punto no es su fin
para determinar un plano que sucede con
dos puntos
qué pasa si por aquí pongo un punto b
por ejemplo un punto b que esté en la
intersección de estos dos planos bueno
pues esa intersección de los dos planos
justo es una recta tenemos esta recta de
acá que también es la recta ave vale y
resulta que estos dos planos que dibujé
tienen tanto aa como ave de hecho tienen
a toda la recta que pasa por ahí por ver
y pues de la misma manera que lo hicimos
con un punto aquí también podemos rotar
todos estos planos ahora alrededor de
esta recta y eso nos define una
infinidad de planos que pasan por ahí
por ver por ejemplo podría tener un
tercer plano que va más o menos así como
por así como por ahí algo de este estilo
vaya espero que se vea más o menos la
idea pero existe es que podemos rotar
para obtener muchísimos planos y por lo
tanto dos puntos todavía no son
suficientes para determinar un único
plano bueno qué sucedería con tres
puntos con tres puntos hay que ser un
poco más cuidadosos
porque por ejemplo si ese tercer punto
lo pongo aquí en la recta ave si ahí
pongo un punto ce entonces todavía hay
una infinidad de planos que pasan por a
b y c
todos estos planos que rota vamos
también pasan por por el punto c y por
lo tanto pasan por los tres puntos vale
entonces hay que tener cuidado con tres
puntos si si están los tres en una misma
recta entonces hay una infinidad de
planos que pasan por ellos pero qué
sucede si tomamos ahora un punto fuera
de la recta ab por ejemplo déjame tomar
un punto digamos pues que esté en el
primer plano que dibuje por acá y le voy
a llamar d será posible que otro de
estos planos que giremos también pase
por d pues no o sea realmente al girar
sólo chocamos una vez con d y por lo
tanto hay un único plano que pasa por a
por b y por d entonces tres puntos sí
bastan si bastan para determinar un
plano siempre y cuando esos tres puntos
no sean con lineales vale o sea aquí ab
están en una misma recta verde están en
una misma recta y que están en una misma
recta porque dos puntos siempre
en una misma recta pero a b y d
no están los tres al mismo tiempo en una
misma recta vale bueno entonces tres
puntos que no sean con lineales definen
un plano ahora vamos a este ejercicio de
acá lo que nos piden es determinar
varias formas de llamarle al plano s a
este plano de acá bueno por lo que
platicamos de este lado para hacer eso
tenemos que encontrar varias ternas de
puntos no alineados que estén en el
plano ese entonces por ejemplo al plano
s también podríamos llamarle déjame
tomar el color el color azul claro
también podríamos llamarle el plano el
plano a bj porque son puntos no no con
lineales a bj o bien el plano a w j
el plano
a w j o también el plano jw un el plano
plano j wv y bueno podría ponerle más
nombres cambiando las letras pero
básicamente esos son los únicos tipos
distintos de ternas que podemos tener
bueno entonces ahí tenemos tres nombres
y bueno lo que no se vale lo que no se
vale es llamarle el plano wv lo voy a
poner en color rojo porque no se vale el
plano
wv este de aquí no se vale y no se vale
porque b&w están los tres en la recta l
es decir son co lineales y por lo tanto
hay una infinidad de planos que pasan
por a por bay w no sólo ese sino todas
las rotaciones de ese alrededor de él